bref côté mme bauza office il est en
train de nous faire une grosse
dépression vous allez devoir être
dépaysé jean narboni vous avez déjà
essayé dépaysé un paysan
est magnifique
[Musique]
les denrées alimentaires sont interdits
d'abord madame
un bidon la vache
horrifiée 1re étoile
[Musique]
maintenant ton médicament c'est la paye
lampe
au 12 juin j'aurais jamais cru voir
sakho vivant pro merci merci car j'aime
papa l'attendait sous le monsieur là et
s'ouvre on
l'a alors rien du temps au temps des cow
boys des
allergies dans la procédure s'il ya un
bouton calme pas forcément à québec où
s'élevait la même occasion tu pouvais
trouver l'interrupteur pour fermer ta
gueule
alors je récapitule parce que c'est la
première fois que j'en fais
dessus à la relance à catherine est mon
pote souffre
vous êtes un camion comme peu place
[Musique]
toujours le sourire
argen l'adresse
musharraf
les commenter cette télécommande c'est
la climatisation et le go il a dit que
surtout pas y toucher à ça
c'est bien ils ont saisi 2 veut que jane
acquis bleus